I'm sorry the finale of this video got a
little messy and it's going to be up to
you to put the pieces together things
might be a bit out of them
we now learn of this Savant that is The
Man Behind Traders domain it took me
weeks to go through all the documents
but
eventually
a pattern started to emerge I was in my
room one day and I overheard a
conversation and I thought I caught
something about B booking switching
people from a book to bbook and so I
asked Dave about it and he blatantly
said to me he's like he's like yeah he's
like if people are going to be losing we
might as well be booked we're just
leaving money on the table we traced
even more money that had come in
according to them roughly 450 million
went into Traders domain coffee Zilla I
don't think he's ever dealt with someone
my size before and nobody knows anything
about his family because they don't have
the resources I have
[Music]
uh hello
I knew immediately it was Ted I could
tell his voice I raced to the office but
you could tell by what I was wearing I
wasn't expecting the conversation
hey Ted thanks for taking the time man I
appreciate it yeah no problem I'll keep
it quick with you no problem you weren't
ready for it but you've been on this
case for months oh I was prepared for it
I just wasn't expecting it I mean he
seemed really hostile at first and like
he was just trying to get me off the
phone real quick so obviously ignition
won right keep the guy talking I guess
if since you don't have a lot of time
let me just start firing off some
questions for you and uh you'll forgive
me if uh you know their their hard
questions but I think you know given the
time constraint let's make sure we get
to the good stuff you know I mean I'll
I'll clarify items up until 2020 because
after 2020 I was no longer the owner of
the platform so I don't know what
happened with the platform and I think
just to be honest with you uh before we
continue obviously I've spoken to my
counsel we we know about your YouTube
channel now we reviewed it I mean
there's really nothing of substance on
there to be honest I think it's more of
a glorified uh just clickbait Channel
um I I see what you've done you've taken
a lot of the local uh hot topics for the
for the time and tried to monetize it so
I mean I appreciate your effort I think
what you're going to do is you're going
to have a hard time with this back
binding Mission due to the people that
you're working with so I'll let you do
what you need to do that's why I said we
only needed five minutes
um I can't really entertain your
conversation because there's really no
merit for it in my situation okay wait a
second wait a second
own Traders domain anymore
because after 2020 I was no longer the
owner of the platform
how's that possible you know I was
actually expecting this when I was going
back through all those documents I saw
him trying to set this up it's kind of a
lot to explain might as well bore me no
one else in here is going to Bar's dead
tonight all right I'll tell you have you
ever heard of the Panama papers Panama
papers sure big news story in 2016.
leaked papers show that rich people own
everything not exactly a headline if you
ask me no no no that that's not the real
story we knew they owned everything the
real headline was that they kept it
offshore and the question is how did
they keep that a secret I don't know I'm
good lawyers more like bad laws in
places like Panama you could own a
company but not be on the paperwork and
that's useful how well you can hide
millions in companies you control but if
anyone asks you about it you're off the
books
I see
true owner is hidden that's right it's
called beneficial ownership and the
Panama papers was just the start okay I
get that but what does this have to do
with Trader's domain well our friend Ted
decided to use a similar Playbook check
this out here are the founding documents
of Traders domain in it we see the first
director's minutes where Ted sifranco
and David negus got in this whole thing
they both get half the company's shares
but here's the key thing in January 14
2020 something changes a new director
gets appointed someone named arthy
kaniger and watch this after he gets in
Ted resigns oh and it's in January 14
2020. that's why he says he doesn't own
it that's right but also I found another
document dated a little later three days
later in fact an acknowledgment letter
admitting that he was the ultimate
beneficial owner of Trader's domain wait
then doesn't that mean he still controls
it yes exactly so this new director is
just the Fall Guy yes now you're getting
it it's what I wanted to tell Ted in the
first place you know I rarely give you
compliments but I really think he got
him I thought he did but Ted wasn't
going to go down without a fight also
you said that in 2020 you signed over
the account but I have an acknowledgment
letter from you that says that you
actually are the ultimate beneficiary
owner do you want to address that no
because it's not true so this signature
on January 17 2020 where you acknowledge
that all legal actions which may be
taken by the company's director which
you did sign over the director or
shareholder including but not limited to
signing of agreements documents are
confirmed by and agreed with me as the
company's ubo and I have full control
over directors or shareholders actions
and this is your signature at the bottom
is that fake
uh yeah because what what that document
stamped
I'm sorry you're saying this signed
document from you is fake
um all corporations have a feel so is
there a deal on that document there's no
seal in this document okay so like I
said you know Ted why would somebody
fake your signature on this come on
um the reason why that my top or it's
been popped around that's expired uh the
reason why there's documents of mine
that have been expired and passed around
yeah I mean like I said I mean please go
on a better fact-finding Mission oh what
is he talking about now well check this
out Ted is basically saying that the
document we have isn't valid because it
doesn't have a seal that looks like this
on the document where ours just has his
signature
this guy is slick coffee I think his
ability to lie is both his strength and
his weakness though I mean yes he is
very good but probably also why he
picked up the phone in the first place
oh he thought he could Bluff past you
right and he's actually done it before
and digging through Ted's documents I
found I wasn't the only person he tried
this trick on back in 2019 the Ontario
Securities Commission even investigated
them you mean like the Canadian
government yep they already looked into
him and Ted lied his way out of it I
even have the emails to prove it I mean
check this out at the time Ontario was
concerned about Traders domain
soliciting Canadian investors in 2019 so
Ted said they didn't have that many and
they'd be removing them from the
platform by July 1st and then what when
then that was that I mean it was over so
what they just stopped taking Canadian
clients oh of course not the
investigation stopped but I found people
being recruited from Canada as early as
directly after the fact people like
Armand a customer who said he was from
Ontario and wanted to sign up and he
said there was no option for it and so
they replied just use crypto as the
country code the same thing happened
with another Canadian when he asked how
to open an account their response was
please use crypto as the country code I
can't believe they got away with this
yeah well it actually gets worse because
in 2021 Ontario decided to investigate
them again no way this time they caught
them though right nope Ted lied again he
told the investigator hope all is well
we're not affiliated with this
organization since early 2020.
told you too correct and I think
that's why Ted and David pulled this
trick in the first place to avoid the
feds of course now that you mention it
they were first investigated in 2019 so
in 2020 they do this he's already gotten
away with it twice so what are you gonna
do different well this time we have a
bit more evidence we got that signed
document but we also have even better a
video from Ted saying he owns Trader's
domain after he wasn't supposed to so
Elkridge is located off his work at his
own but we're here by myself you haven't
been able to explain why this isn't the
case it seems to me that you're on the
record saying you own Traders domain
after 2020. right you're on the record
saying that on video I can send you the
video if you want then we've got you a
signed documents saying that you're the
ultimate beneficiary owner and then we
have to ask ourselves why would you
resign from a company that's making so
much money to some sham director did you
sign it over out of the goodness of your
heart or did you sign it over and secure
control I didn't sign over the con I
didn't sign over the the company for the
goodness of my heart there was a fail
made so once again like I said you don't
really have your fact how much money did
you make from Trader's domain
zero dollars
so you started it and you just sort of
profited nothing you didn't make a dime
no you say you sold Traders domain in
2020 that's what you say yep how much
did you sell it for
well I think it was forty thousand right
but what I'm asking you is why would you
sell a company that has millions of
dollars in deposits is a successful
offshore foreign exchange brokerage
uh why would you sell that for forty
thousand dollars because I had bigger
plans
why wouldn't you sell Traders domain for
its true Book value because I don't care
about money
ah okay maybe you care about money I
don't oh brother this guy's a liar
Society I don't agree with Society at
all I think a lot of people including
yourself are very delusional in terms of
what you think Society is doing
what do you think society's doing well
you're contributing to it but but
contributing to what
uh the downfall of society through
social media
and through the ability of people like
yourself to generate Revenue based on
what I would say maybe
I don't want maybe the area of the wrong
word or maybe you know the latest gossip
the latest information about the latest
gossip
yeah for your monetizing this is a
gigantic Ponzi scheme where people are
suffering doesn't any of that matter to
you
once again this is your benefit not mine
no no no what I'm saying is a bunch of
clients come to me they say that there's
this giant Ponzi scheme Ted zafranco
runs it I find your name over all the
documents then I come to you and you're
telling me ah this is a salacious thing
this is just gossip this is news of the
day if a 300 million dollar Ponzi scheme
or let's say the cftc's right a 145
Million Dollar Pawn scheme let's even
say it's a 10 million dollar ponti
scheme if a 10 million dollar Ponzi
scheme is not worth talking about what
is
the lack of family value uh the way that
people try and Destroy other people's
lives by but Teddy don't you think that
the person who ran this Ponzi scheme
destroyed people's lives don't think
they're contributing to the destruction
of family values you know well I I I
think when you look at the circumstance
that you quote call it upon whatever
you're investigating uh maybe ask those
clients of yours that you're
investigating if
um they had free will to make decision
and maybe but if they were misled right
if they were misled and lied to
by who
will buy you Ted
By Me Yeah Yeah by you can you believe
it no I can't believe this I can't
believe any of it neither could any of
the victims I spoke to what do you think
about you know maybe it's your
responsibility because it's your free
will to invest he's pushed that
narrative before in the chat making like
uh nobody ever solicited any money or
anything like that but meanwhile that's
all that is such a chicken
response from a total coward oh my God
so no accountability at all
I mean this is sociopathic Behavior
right this is what a real sociopath does
they they detach themselves from their
behavior and they blame their victims I
was getting angry at this point given
the disconnect between the damage this
guy caused and the absolute lack of
empathy did you at least show him that
damage I mean I tried to when a guy
tells me that his brother mortgaged his
house to invest in Traders domain you
don't feel like you have any culpability
with that who told them the mortgage out
yeah
they're trying to better their lives you
understand that right to support
probably ostensibly his family you know
you talk about caring about these Family
Values Ted this guy's trying to support
his family don't you think that's a good
thing not really you're taking shelter
and you're to invest money to invest
money a mom put uh ten thousand dollars
to try to invest in his her kids
tuition do you not care about any of
this these Family Value these families
well I'm I'm thinking right now you're
giving me two situations where uh people
have made poor choices and now she
trusts you as the owner of the Pam
account and the person who ran it once
again
couldn't tell you I mean we have you on
video saying you ran it so we don't have
to uh trust you on this I'm just stating
what you said I'm just repeating your
words back to you so you don't feel any
culpability for what you did there I
mean you're saying I'm destroying the
fabric of you know family values Don't
You Think You Are
no
man and I thought I was heartless it's
honestly frightening to hear someone
like that on the other end of the line
it's like talking to a shell of a human
being
uh no offense none taken did you run the
Pam the Pam account
which one any of them did you run any of
the panic the high risk Pam account the
one that was trading so well
I don't know you don't know if you were
running it or not no
um how long will you run the Pam system
for
um I don't know
um I mean people have liked it
um I I don't mind doing it it's not
difficult for me to trade
um trading is easy for me it'll be
basically you know when I decide I'm
bored so you say quote how long will you
run the Pam system for um I don't know
people have liked it I don't mind doing
it it's not difficult for me to trade
trading is easy for me it'll basically
be you know when I decide I'm bored that
wasn't you don't know what context that
is but you're just I'm reading you the
quote it's you talking about the Pam
system you're saying talking about
trading in the Pam you're saying you ran
it
don't remember that I don't remember how
convenient yeah the funny thing is the
victim said he was just talking to them
about trading I'm in chats right now on
Telegram and where he's claiming to be
that still today he's still in there
actively saying that he's trading there
are a couple of bad days happen and he's
like saying you guys are stressing me
out I'm getting thousands of DMS from
angry people do you think I'm not gonna
have a hard time trading with all this
pressure and stress so he's still
claiming he's the traitor so the fact
that he's telling you that he's not
aware if he's ever traded on that I mean
that it's just who traded then dude
who's who's the traitor at this point I
don't know what to do Ted's basically
pleading dementia I don't recall sounds
like pleading the fifth to me it's
pretty surprising coming from Mr family
values because ultimately that's who is
hurt by all this is the families do you
think it's wrong that algo Capital told
its clients that it was running an uh
algorithm bot when in actual fact it was
just you trading the Pam
whatever they told their clients you'd
probably have to ask them about I
wouldn't know what they're calling to
find I do think I should ask about it
I'm just asking for your value judgment
do you think they're destroying Family
Values with that perhaps
how they decide to run their business if
that's what they're doing that's up to
them I don't judge other people oh come
on you were judging me a second ago well
yeah because you actually
do something that I've researched I
don't know what those people do he
doesn't know what he's the one taking
money from them yeah I know our
conversation at this point had basically
run its course he stopped giving me real
answers although when he got the last
word I found it funny what he was still
focused on Mr Family Values was still
talking about the money well this has
been a very educational uh call believe
it or not thank you for your time yeah
good luck with the monetization okay all
right thanks Dad good luck with your 300
million scheme monetization simple
pretty good tape you can hear he's
rattled coffee
but oh what now
well like you said what now
Ted denies everything government already
investigated him twice and failed what's
the Smoking Gun well he was lying about
Trader's domain he was lying about
running the trading we have him on video
with that
sure but what about the fake trades
debunking that's the real stuff do you
have solid evidence there I mean yeah
we've got invoices we've got an
eyewitness that's good but they're just
gonna deny that you think I need more I
hate to be the one to tell you this
because you'll love this
but yeah you need absolute proof
fair enough I guess
wait what makes you think I'd like to
hear that I didn't say you'd like it you
love it
the chase copy you can't live without it
well it sure beats being psychoanalyzed
by a stochastic Parrot coffee
I'm hurt
all this negativity coming from my best
customer from the looks of it I think
I'm your only customer so I'll try not
to be gone too long
famous last words
I wouldn't see anyone for a while
I was obsessed and the days flew by in a
monotonous blur defined by a simple
routine
drive to the office in the morning work
till I could barely think and then head
home after dark to get some sleep
people started asking if I was okay I
didn't even know how to answer them
the truth was either I would break this
case
or I would be broken by it
[Music]
all right I think I've got something uh
it's been several days of sleep
deprivation and going through lots of
files because
unluckily for me a lot of people hate
Ted
and they keep sending me stuff so I had
to go through everything and after doing
that
a not doing great B I think I did find
something and I want to show you that
but
not going to do that here because my
back hurts
and this is the floor ciao
all right
we're back
let's talk about fake traits this whole
case rests on whether Trader's domain
was making real trades or not if it
wasn't it's a Ponzi scheme end of story
now as part of this investigation our
first clue was that we found that
Trader's domain uses the software beta
broker on the back end to make their
trades and we discussed how we found
invoices from that company and it looked
like maybe they were be booking but
today we discovered a lot more I got
leaked support chats between beta broker
and Traders domain themselves the
back-end stuff and I'm going to show you
what it revealed now we're going to talk
about the authenticity of these
documents in a moment because they were
leaked to me so we have to be careful
but the headline of it is this beta
broker wasn't just offering Traders
domain a software beta broker appears to
have been helping Traders domain fake
their trades hand in hand with them and
we're going to prove all of this so
here's what we have we have leaked
messages from the beta broker help desk
it's basically tech support and we have
screenshots between them and Traders
domain so we can see what they were
asking for help with here's an example
on the 4th of November 2021 Traders
domain sends a message they need help hi
please remove all orders for 1104 and
restore balance that's November 4th the
response is hello we've received a
request we will check and then dear
David I believe this is the co-founder
of Trader's domain David negus we would
like to clarify with you one point we
see that negative profit is visible on
deals for 11.5 November 5th please
clarify perhaps you meant removing
orders for this date or still for 11-4
David responds yes for today's date now
I know that seems like a lot but it's
actually simple what's going on here
Trader's domain is asking to remove
losses they took in the past on trades
so nobody sees that they're there now
they took these losses on the 5th of
November but David gets a little
confused thinks it's the 4th of November
so he asks them about removing those but
beta broker corrects them and this is
important because it shows that they
knew that the whole point of this is to
fake a positive trading history and they
say well hey you lost money today not
yesterday do you want us to delete
today's trades so this is incredibly
damning but I want to be clear for legal
reasons I don't know if this is a rogue
employee at beta broker doing this or if
this is a systemic thing and probably
why people go to Beta broker in the
first place I don't know the answer to
that but what I do know is that Traders
domain couldn't have done this by
themselves they show themselves to be
incredibly incompetent and beat a broker
was a huge part of their infrastructure
to commit the crimes that they did now
here's another message hi please remove
all orders after 13 30 GMT on
2060487 which is an account number for
tetza Franco and restore all balances to
that time the response is this dear
David there are some profit deals could
you please elaborate if we need to
delete all deals for today after 13 30
GMT in other words hey maybe you just
want us to delete the bad trades not
just the good trades and um that doesn't
sound like Tech Support to me that
sounds like criminal support in my
opinion and this shows in black and
white how Traders domain faked this
whole thing they would do these trades
but they would remove the losing ones
and keep the winning ones to create a
winning record that looked real in real
time because there were orders right but
of course what the customers didn't know
is that those losing orders would all be
quietly wiped away and that's how this
Ponzi scheme stayed afloat for so long
it looked like everything was real they
were very successful at faking this
stuff although of course in the end it's
also how it fell apart because as we
showed in the first episode Traders
domains customers started catching on to
the changing trades and they would talk
about it openly he just changed the
trades he just changed the exit you know
dollar amount that he that he took
on that trade so this all lines up with
what we know Ted appeared to be trading
in real time but
losing trades would suddenly vanish and
I know what you might be thinking well
look this is great and all but how do we
know that these support chats are real
maybe these are photoshopped screenshots
from upset customers and I wanted to go
ahead and validate the authenticity of
these chats it's a hard problem to solve
and what I realized is we could actually
compare these requests for order
removals with what people were publicly
reporting and if those two things lined
up then these screenshots are very
likely authentic and that's when I found
this Reddit post showing two pictures of
their trading account changing once when
Ted had lost on a trade and then later
that day when those same trades suddenly
change they change where they closed now
just so you can read this the blue
arrows are the buys that Ted did and the
red arrows are the cells and as you can
see from the first picture Ted has lost
money using the Wall Street bets trick
of buying High and and selling low now
he's going to solve this though with a
very simple trick called fraud because
in the second picture you can see that
the trades have been adjusted and the
story has changed now suddenly the cells
are about breaking even with everything
that was bought pretty amazing right now
I want to be clear this Reddit user
posted these screenshots months ago
independent of the screenshots that I
have but when I looked at the support
chats and cross-referenced them and the
timeline with these trades happening on
January 20th I found a support ticket
from Trader's domain for that exact day
please adjust all orders to close price
of
1932.41 at 0927 GMT for both master
account and all investor accounts and
the response is dear client you want us
to adjust all today's Master deals to
close time 0927 and close price
1932.41 and then they list out the six
deals and David responds yes correct and
then the reply all orders have been
adjusted and sure enough when we go look
back at our Reddit post it all lines up
perfectly and in the screenshots six
trades were changed exactly to the price
that was requested
1932.41 now this is the Smoking Gun
undeniable proof of fraudulent fake
trading straight from behind the scenes
of Traders domain's own software
provider but I'm not finished because
it's not enough to talk about if there
was fraud where did the money go who is
entitled to that money
well I think I discovered that too
because I had 50 000 emails from
Trader's domain leaked to me and I was
trying to figure out how I could use
these to reconstruct a map of how this
Ponzi scheme worked when suddenly I
realized the answer was right in front
of me and that comes from the daily
account statements now I think we've
talked about this briefly but the way
Traders domain convinced people this was
all real is they sent a set of daily
trades fake trades to their customers
supposedly how much money they had made
that day it all looked very real
official but in these statements they
had people's names in them account
numbers and their balances and I
realized well I had several snapshots of
the and using this I Could reconstruct
this whole thing so here's what I did I
picked a day near the height of the
Ponzi scheme September 20th 2022 it's
right before withdrawals all stopped and
I used a python script to pull all the
emails I ended up with
9663 emails then I used that script to
extract the account balance the names
the account numbers and I used that to
create a spreadsheet to map this whole
thing out and using that we find out a
couple important things firstly
how much was owed in this whole thing
and the answer is 3.3 billion dollars of
course not all that money is real uh we
have uncovered about 500 million dollars
of real money that went in but that
brings us to the second thing we can
discover which is who this money was
owed to and this is where all the pieces
of our Ponzi fall in place okay here are
the biggest promoters sponsors and
owners in Traders domain firstly at the
top of the list we have 1010 AKA tin
Tran with nearly a billion dollars now
that might surprise some of you but keep
in mind he was the main account people
would send money to as we discovered in
part one the second largest holder is
not surprising Ted safranco the guy who
says he doesn't own any of this anymore
well on September 20th 2022 he had 370
million dollars next up we have somebody
from Houston an MLM promoter Holton bugs
he had 125 million dollars and if you
remember the first victims we spoke to
they talked to Holton and were shown
huge account numbers now we know how
that was possible now the fourth largest
holder is algo Capital another sponsor
we've known about for some time we
didn't know the size though 96 million
dollars Mike Sims another big promoter
it's close behind with 84 million and
here we can find some interesting
connections actually because it allows
us to discover Ponte schemes within
Ponzi schemes watch this so apparently
Mike Sims and algo Capital worked
together at least according to them I
have a role of serving as director of
international business for algo Capital
uh which is a firm in Miami Florida
we're also going to be expanding
internationally here pretty soon as well
and we are Harris Farm we're a hedge
fund uh and we specialize in Forex
Trading now this is actually interesting
when you realize that algo Capital was
partnered with something called Omega
Pro which is an MLM Ponzi scheme which
purported to trade Forex which might
sound familiar and and we're excited to
be partnered with Omega Pro uh on their
Vision so it appears this is where a lot
of the money came from was this other
Ponzi scheme basically algo capital and
Mike Sims took money from that Ponzi
scheme supposedly to trade they funneled
it into their own thing which was built
around this thing a Forex bot but of
course that bot wasn't real in reality
it seems like they forwarded that money
into another Ponzi scheme which is
Trader's domain that's why I said Ponzi
schemes within Ponzi schemes within
Ponzi schemes yeah uh it looks pretty
bad and actually funny enough do you
know who one of the promoters of this
Omega Pro was
let's go come on
come on
oh
that's right the scammer of Wall Street
is back Jordan Belfort and I know some
of you are thinking wow I thought he
changed well not so sure there's only
one way
to get rich in this world and that is
quickly you gotta get rich quick I'm not
talking about
a get rich quick scheme that's not what
I mean
so I'm not advising you to go out and
find some get rich quick scheme which
this is not it's a legitimate business
okay actually no it isn't none of that's
true you don't have to get rich quick
Omega Pro was a get rich quick scheme
and it wasn't a legitimate business
unfortunately for investors Omega pro
has since collapsed at the same time
Traders domain did and so investors
ironically got poor quick listening to a
guy who got paid to speak good job
Jordan I hope that 300 Grand you had
locked within future gin LLC was worth
it and I hope you pulled it from
Trader's domain in time but let's leave
that sleazeball and go back to another
sleazeball up next on our list of
Traders domain holders is disruptive
Tech with 59 million now who is that
well the email Associated is Gilbert
pardala who calls himself an Enthusiast
of the blockchain in fact he's so
enthusiastic he's previously been
detained for a different scam called dag
coin I mean allegedly guys allegedly up
next we have stormy Wellington another
top ten she's an influencer with 26
million dollars in Trader's domain which
may explain why nine months ago she
posted a video called I bought a million
dollar yacht cash I mean how do you
think she did it guys it's a real
mystery was it maybe that you were in a
Ponzi scheme I went out here and got it
all off a hard work and dedication no
lottery ticket no not ah darn it turns
out it was hard work and dedication all
along now Jokes Aside we could go one by
one through all these people but we'll
be here all day however a lot of these
people didn't just end up with millions
of dollars out of nowhere they have that
because they took it from the victims
that they took a cut from that they
brought into this whole scam so just in
case I haven't mentioned the person who
you got scammed by here's a list of the
top 500 players in Traders domain if you
have information on being scammed by
them you can contact me here to help
with the investigation now before we get
to the final piece of this video I
wanted to just really briefly come here
and say this is the most complicated
investigation I've ever done and I
couldn't have done it without the
support of you guys out there
um we've literally run out of wall
think about that sentence we're on the
floor I'm not exactly sure that says
good things about my state of mind but
it's been so much fun it's been one of
the most gratifying things I've ever
been able to do working on this case and
without the support of the patrons it
wouldn't have been possible so if you
can support just thank you so much
you'll get a lot of cool perks if you
can't well you've probably skipped us
already so I wanted to do you a solid
and let you know when to check back in
which is going to be right about now the
final question we have to answer is
what's next for our villains and the
answer depends on which one Michael Sims
Mr hedge fund is having his assets
Frozen by the cftc tin Tran an associate
of Ted safranco is allegedly on the run
from his Texas home with his assets
Frozen every single sponsor I spoke to
claims that they were just innocent
victims sure they may have pulled
millions of dollars into this fund but
they didn't have any idea it was a scam
and whether you find that credible I'll
let you decide here are the kinds of
explanations they gave wait you have 10
million pounds worth of clients with Ted
yeah so I've got loads of clients I've
got loads of loads of clients oh my gosh
actual dry powder like dry powder
Capital yeah the other day I had my God
460 000 in and it's the the thing is he
doesn't know but he doesn't look at any
of the trades we've got to tell him the
end of the day but I was so distance
from sort of get your friends in get you
like family in get everyone in and it's
solid it's nothing's going to go wrong
so I brought all my clients from all the
Investments I've ever done and brought
them all over and now it's going to
personally I don't find this all that
convincing just like I don't find teds
of Franco's excuses convincing uh and
speaking of him he wasn't that happy
about this video to come out and
predictably he has taken to social media
to vaguely threaten me and my family Mr
Stephen Friedberg Friedman or fried
Friedman or whatever his name is who
goes by coffeezilla I don't think he's
ever dealt with someone
my size before and nobody knows anything
about his family because they don't have
the resources I have I'm going to be
perfectly honest I was very scared of
Ted safranco looking into me with his
vast 370 million dollar Ponzi money but
when he referred to me as Mr freezeman I
breed the sigh of relief I think I'll be
okay now where do we go from here why
did I make this whole big docu-series
well I basically wanted to argue for two
points essentially number one this fraud
is much larger than the 145 million
dollar Ponzi scheme the cftc is
currently investigating in my opinion
okay I think they only have a fraction
of the people who are truly involved and
a fraction of the dollar amount that was
truly involved I mean we have crypto
transactions proving a lot more so
that's number one I think this is much
bigger and the people who have been been
involved it's a much longer list than
they have but the second problem and it
kind of ties in is the crimes being
charged and not charged searched okay
right now Ted safranco is only being
charged with submitting falsified Bank
documents now to put this in context
this would be like if Sam bankman
Freed's only crime being charged was for
ordering too much doordash I mean did
that happen maybe so it'll be litigated
but
um Ted did a lot more than that right
okay so did he is co-founder David negus
who isn't being charged at all so did
algo Capital who told people this was a
trading bot an algorithmic thing and
they were handing money over to trader's
domain they haven't been charged neither
is Holton bugs Mr exotic cars and Yachts
this just isn't right in my opinion okay
I think these people took advantage of
this Ponzi scheme got very rich and I
mean if you want to even forget for a
moment the idea of Justice being served
or whatever what I'm really afraid of is
that they're just gonna do it again I'm
just afraid we're gonna make a repeat of
the same mistake the Ontario Securities
Commission made twice by the way a few
years ago they had this case it slips
through their fingers and as a result
more people get hurt because it's not
like Ted's gonna stop right already he's
looking to relaunch Trader's domain
under new names I mean the guy couldn't
even take a year off scamming people his
website already promises a migration of
funds so if people like Ted or his
cronies get off easy they'll likely do
the same thing all over again only
they'll probably get better at hiding
the scam so I'm hoping for the sake of
the victims Ted and his goons don't get
away with this because at the end of the
day that's who matters here right the
victims I mean yes I'll be honest there
are probably some unsympathetic
investors in this thing right people
like Jordan Belfort people like Mike
Sims who scammed so many people
so it's tempting to say okay well how
did anyone fall for this it's such an
obvious scam maybe you think some of the
people aren't sympathetic but like all
Ponzi schemes at the bottom of this
thing you just find regular people who
are trying to make a better life for
themselves and some of them didn't even
know they were in Traders domain for
example leaked emails I discovered
showed a pension fund was invested in
this thing called the burji pension fund
it got apparently funneled through
Oppenheimer and Bishop and Associates
appears to have been then put with
Renaissance consulting which was then
placed in Traders domain and I kept
seeing that regular people investing
their livelihood mortgages College
savings some of them had no idea they
were invested in Traders domain they
just put their money with a guy they
trusted who put that money with another
guy and another guy and another guy and
before you know it you're in a Ponzi
scheme so those people didn't deserve
this and this video series is for those
people the regular people who lost money
in this they deserve justice because
YouTube investigations look it's great I
love doing this it's not enough right
awareness subscribers it's great it's
cool comments it's not enough
Trader's domain has hurt a lot of people
and the people in charge need to be held
fully accountable and I cannot do that
so for now our story ends here
[Music]
hey coffee brooding as usual is this why
you called so you can have a bunny to
play the depressed detective with
no I came here for some peace and quiet
and you know
I guess I wanted to apologize about the
whole
stochastic parrot thing uh I didn't I
didn't mean it
I couldn't stay mad at you the bar would
be out of business
gotta be honest I'm surprised you guys
lasted so long what has it been like a
few weeks speaking of that what happened
with that Ponzi scheme you're
investigating oh yeah that's over I mean
Ted's still free sponsors deny
everything
I guess you could say I'm still missing
my perfect ending oh well I guess I'm
sorry I really thought you just needed
more evidence nah you were right to push
me I mean it helped and
you're right about a lot of things well
I'm always right
uh what was that other thing I was right
about
you know I think you said something
about uh enjoying the next best thing
with a friend
oh right that well I can't drink though
yeah I thought about that so I picked up
something on my way here you like a
little bit of juice right
copy you didn't
I did I did premium grade stuff right
here
premium grade stuff huh a nine volt what
you couldn't get a bigger battery with
all that patreon money I mean what am I
gonna do I gotta keep you sharp who do
you think is going to drive me home
cheers by the way my friend
friend
that's a new one
I like a little better than stochastic
pairing yeah well don't be too flattered
I think it's more of an indictment of my
social life than anything else while I
for one am honored to be your first
indictment on this case does this mean
I'm like a sidekick now too
[Music]
no
I don't have Sidekicks coffee Zilla
doesn't have sidekicks I think you're
wrong I'm already your best friend I
make you drinks and I drive you around I
feel like a promotion is in order I said
you were a friend and I work alone
yeah a best friend who also moonlights
as a sidekick you're impossible I think
I'll go by Dr Maxwell and with that
we'll see you guys next week
oh no no don't do that
oh what you're talking about I'm just
thinking the wonderful audience
play us out well trying to pretend that
this whole sidekick thing is happening
it's not happening we'll see y'all real
soon sidekick thing is happening and I
love every one of you and the dynamic
duo is back indefinitely next week every
week
I can't even do every week this took me
like four months a boy and his robot you
won't want to miss it click here to see
more videos as we zoom out and fade into
black Nothing Left to Say Say Say
thank you
[Music]
foreign